uh uh the woman
has been murdered i don't know she was
killed
somebody got married okay
and but they also said that tomorrow
they're having a funeral for someone who
isn't dead who's the hit on is my
question
like who oh alexa oh we are killing here
i'll give you the
i'll give you the head down a lot or
will i there you go
we're killing alexa carlisle she's the
lady of the staff to pick up
oh she got that phase ancient english
origin
uh yeah i don't know
sure
should we kill the butler he's leading
you somewhere important
yeah you'd follow the light bulb right
now he's showing you the
crime scene so you can start
investigating we got to figure out who
killed this person
do you actually have to solve the
mystery i don't know
that would be very unique hitman twist
yeah just yeah completely before
[Laughter]
sorry i wasn't listening can you repeat
all of that
suicide however
madam carlisle suspects
foul play i've prepared some information
for you i like this
the whole manor setting i really want
you to stuff somebody in a grandfather
clock
that would be cool to my right
oh mr exactly to your right okay the
crime scene's in here
all right slip in there and disguise
yourself in the chat murder mystery 47.
okay i trust you'll get to the bottom of
this
oh there are corpse in the bed this is
oh my god
throat markings indicate a rare
short-lived plan poison killed him
nightshade or whatever it's called of
death at around 10 o'clock
last night or whiskey
a rare shot lived poison whiskey
hello
[Music]
so we're gonna figure out crimes
together they already started a little
bit before i started we're playing on pc
for the record
do you have to take pictures elderly
porn gameplay mechanic
yeah that you have a cam you don't have
to take pictures but your camera just
scans things
interesting like in the last mission i
pointed my camera
at a door oh look how cute you look
whoa who is this cutie snazzy you can go
to a
rooftop hangout after this
look at that filthy [ __ ] hipster man
look at him
oh gosh cool though i
i have played through um the first one
not the second one so i don't know how
much is different
from one to two into three but these
games rule
you've likely seems not exhausted
how does she know how does she know
really just she's the cameraman she's
like the lack of two in mario 64.
yeah oh yeah she's she's on a little
cloud following you around you never see
us
suicide note oh that's exciting a sample
of handwriting i do want to solve this
even though we don't need to
compare to other samples too you know
you've made it when you can store all
your liquor inside a globe
but i'm not in the closet just me
interesting
an empty closet hmm
[Music]
um there's got to be something else
there's the chair
let me think hmm i mean he
he clearly was poisoned
and that yeah because nobody buys
wellingtons and then kills themselves
okay everybody knows that that would be
ridiculous he mentioned
plants earlier one of like those plants
on one side of the room on the opposite
side of the uh where the laptop was
who's this guy also outside too
smart jacob yeah looks like there's just
lots of plants going on in here
maybe it's a poisonous plant yes
all right uh i'm an astronaut to the
person who asked
i like how investigating means just
running up against everything
until you get a problem um i played the
games in 1080.
oh 16 might not
hitman 1 has loads of peepholes too and
none of them do anything
it's the strangest thing yeah they're
just everywhere and they don't have any
purpose
it's just to see it's so weird searching
the secret
ins and outs of oh is that like a
one-way mirror
i believe you've done a photo oh it is
yeah that was the one that we
uh posed in front of it's time to see
the butler
i'm curious about the information he's
prepared how far into the game oh
you guys were playing for like an hour
before i joined this is the second
mission this seems so elaborate like it
almost seems like tutorials it's got to
be which one is the hole
i think it's that one with the creepy
black eyes to your left that's what
i really thought that [ __ ] oh yeah look
at the hole i thought she had to see it
exactly
oh
you took a knife out yeah i tried to
take my camera
and i took a knife punch you're not
gonna cut that painting
i need more information butler
he's handsome not anymore
you can still be handsome and dead
oh he's up where'd he go
oh my god
hold on
i'm telling you soap i don't want to
kill him you don't want to kill anyone
right good thing you have to watch out
for the maid
just hide how could they know oh
there it is don't worry sometimes you
just accidentally pull a knife out
i'm just the best of us it's okay you're
learning
you're learning how to lay out learning
the enemies learning every angle of this
mystery
i mean these games are designed to be
sandboxes that you replay a bunch of
times
oh yeah failure is okay
i didn't fail keeping says no you didn't
sorry
that might happen a photocopy yeah view
that internet
this time oh you should view that intel
you hit f1
[Music]
the most important clue interesting
but he's been researching the secret ins
and outs of thornbridge manor
i believe you've done a thorough search
of the crime scene 47.
necessary i'm curious about the
information
yeah bad for you old people uh jane
all right butler where are you oh the
person needing to mutter is is upstairs
where are the stairs well we have behind
you alana we can't murder someone
when there's a murderer we have a
mystery to solve a good point
right down there hey butler
mr fernsby huh
i still just don't understand why we're
here to solve a
crime that's very strange mr fernsby
i'm done with the crime scene did you
establish a time of death
zachary died around 10 o'clock last
night look at her
taking a [ __ ] off
i don't understand how you're going to
have a place like this and not have
security cameras
okay all right it's old yeah this is
why we're in the 1920s this is a
flashback
he's been working on that launch he's a
clone in the in the movies
i will take you to madame
thank you for asking samlu my hands are
okay i'm still in a significant amount
of pain
uh watching friends play a game right
now did i take that by
standing over him on the bed we
shouldn't i don't know i think i think
i'll be close
to play games probably this week because
look at all these other people though
so these are all the suspects why are we
solving
i don't know it's really strange oh it
is knives out
question sorry did we really question it
and i feel like we just sort of do i
have to go
question all of them well the question
was he just went no i
don't happen yes i was here
thank you i believe may i suggest you
ask this
i mean i like that they're doing this as
strange as it is to send a hit man to do
it and
like i mean he didn't need to kill the
detective he could have just done his
job
we could just ask him could we solve
this murder or should we just murder
usually question a couple seconds yeah i
think i want you to solve the murder
and then murder where are they
uh a good question which is suspects in
search location i'm not seeing any green
on the map
because they would excuse me do you know
where the family is
yeah hey bro
[Laughter]
yeah i've been working for uh six months
yeah i know where they all sleep
don't worry about it
i was born in winchester can't you tell
[Laughter]
are you the family oh this is a family
oh
my oh oh i'm past the security guard
that's the guy i stabbed with a knife
that is you did put a knife in his eye
yes
yeah this game is pretty
it is the place we were in earlier is
like a big like dubai skyscraper and it
was crazy
damn it was really cool
he just came because he was turning on a
wall next to a lady so he had to go have
a cigarette
oh here we go this you are a suspect
whoa
what about restaurants you like food
let's see
thanks for asking patrick love
sorry man but you're just making me i
need to ask you a question
yeah why would it not why is he
suspicious of you rather than
just letting you ask a question i think
he's having a conversation oh because
he's on the phone
oh i
no but he said you should come visit oh
you're right no weird
weird why is he wearing his patreon
all right well we don't judge people for
that now jacob okay no don't worry about
it
some people do he looks like uh ellie in
the last of us
part two
don't tell mother okay she's really
tense these days and the last thing i
need is more
no it's cool we're gonna kill her i took
that pretty blonde um
rosie uh for an evening
i mean how the [ __ ] am i expected to
cope for an entire weekend in this
[ __ ] i'm
bored out of my mind all right if that's
all i think i'll get back from [ __ ]
if you say
if you say go go put all my matching
pants
wait ask about zachary what did you
think of zachary
creepy as hell no that is creepy imagine
it's the creepiest thing
not having ambition you know father says
zachary and alexa used to be two of a
kind
he had a great future ahead of him then
suddenly
he just gave up everything what an idiot
thank god daddy chose his looks and
brains so
were alexa and and
dead man in a relationship is that it
i think so oh it's well it's usually the
spouse
did you see anything suspicious she does
look particularly nefarious
i reckon zachary tops himself i know i
would have
perhaps mr fernsby i don't like him
he could have done it not a great motive
you not liking him all right that's one
i think it was mr fernsby he smells bad
this is a really good disguise oh you're
going to his office
ransack it steal his [ __ ] there you go
nothing says privacy more than a
transparent door that's a beautiful
office
it really is it's got the hearth got
like racks of wine
oh my god that's how i got it anything
done
is everything ready for tomorrow who is
this kid who he's supposed to
uh oh so this guy he's probably out
gregory gregory oh they're all family
members
yeah yeah cause it's he said only the
family and funds people there and
someone else is one of the person i
think
tell me what you did last night oh and
rosie
oh rosie's the blonde yes patrick
no sorry the guy who said that blonde
oh he said he needed someone real to
talk to others rosie's twin sister she
looks
like does she feel like the center of
the universe
like a real princess get out of here
lady we're having a conversation
does that clear his alibi he's under a
lot of pressure he's an
idiot yeah i mean that guy because that
guy was definitely not well he died
around 10
and she just said they hung out at like
one right
strangers outside the house one
afterwards or one before
no one outside 1am i have a feeling that
when we get to the guy
who did it he'll be like no
i don't know what you're talking about
oh he'll be like i always wanted that
dude's money shame he's dead
anyway bye she's always going on about
how things will change once she's in
charge of thornbridge man
who did that emma they said emma and
emma was saying outside go find emma
yeah where you at
oh wait emma i think emma was the one
getting your photo taken or something
i think you yeah they stopped searching
for you outside finally
after you killed those thank you i
appreciate that
thank you i don't know if you can jeff
if you can take
oh my god female outfits i have no idea
why you guys talking about taco bell
in chat oh the case file
you did make sure she didn't see you
give the other one to the butler
oh of course it's gonna take that
all right hmm
wait this is the front we're supposed to
go out the other end sorry
getting turned around here
oh is there anybody in here oh my god
it's so pretty jesus
yeah good yeah good thought
it might have been him ah a beautiful
picture
can you tell me about yesterday evening
they said emma right they seem to love
each other my brothers and i
i suppose it takes females together
sorry i'm a bit on edge now oh stiff
stuff somebody in that clock patrick
gregory's son disappeared straight yeah
but we know where he went
you know yeah i think he might be in
some sort of trouble
he's depressed or whatever well but
gregory convinced him to stay for a few
drinks before they went off for a pint
at the local at quarter to nine
i swear gregory enjoys edwards okay so
they left before 10.
i had a conference call with my new
yorker what's dead man's name
so i spent andy's all up in here what up
andy cortez
zachary right it is zachary andy cortez
he's in my chat
and you're saying you should ban him
andy serious change is needing to be
done
come visit our chats
stop by
the commentary is way different on our
three different streams
totally different content last night you
know now you mention it
he was a lot more i'm taking this very
seriously more chatty than usual
about my connections in the publishing i
haven't listened to anything
but i am taking it's very serious
she joins me he wasn't the only person
is that everything mr whitmer that was
an odd anything else
detective is not dead he's just resting
inside of a box oh yeah you just knocked
him out didn't you
mm-hmm non-lethal john doesn't kill
i don't know how to i try not to in this
game
is there anything else you want to ask
me nope
i don't think so it's not giving me a
prompt i literally can't
uh but thank you see ya
all right can you be so relaxed oh here
we go
here we go
i think he may have shown up in my chat
too he did oh get rid of him mods
ban him no no no a mother knows
this concerns his future as well all
this will be his
someday exactly he has nothing
oh
emma carla can you tell me where you
were yesterday evening
put on the accent hitman inspect i need
to work yeah
well i spent the year they don't often
do
accents in this game like there's a
mission in hitman one in marrakech where
everyone's still just american i believe
i went up when the beast yeah
that happened in the in the dubai one oh
yeah yeah
where the guy was like welcome to
but we all know that british people
going to dubai is illegal
oops oh [ __ ] you were yesterday evening
wondering about my alibi mr detective
obviously
you dingus i left thornbridge around
half eight
for a pint with edward i wish i hadn't
quiz night at the end that is a huge
bummer when you go and get a beer and
it's quiz night
you didn't know the wife's sporting
another unless you know it's quiz night
and then you
win that's great tiny little different
situation though
when we live he does have a tiny little
mouth
back here but if you open it all the way
you can like reserve
it's very difficult for me to eat a
burger
such as yes i have to cut it into small
it's heavy on the bottle
i have missed it frisbee do it
whatever it is
nothing to us what i think she's scared
to own up to her own mistake
alexa faked her on death to help her
to make her real dad how did you feel i
might as well be honest
who's the last presence
the mother the one you're trying to
correct
she's directly above bears some
responsibility for how this ended
she's dangling from the show she's ready
to strike
by letting him live here is that all did
they remaster all the games someone in
my chat just said i'm glad i hadn't
experienced the series yet now i can
experience all three games in the new
engine
do they put that all three games are in
this no way
was it a new engine well i i thought
they were all made in the same engine
yeah it actually doesn't look like a new
engine but with electricity
still cool alexa photography pretty
we should just kill him you know all
these people seem a little bit shitty
forget about the no i'm so just kill the
whole family i think
oh wait look of camera prompt
who's that was it why
but why what a great picture of somebody
that is
montgomery carlisle oh yes old monty
carlyle
all right so that's almost everyone
right
yeah who is left at this point all right
day to remember i love you i'm so
enthralled with this mystery i know
you're kind of empty
suspect there's zach so we interviewed
him yeah
[Music]
so so it's not he has an alibi yeah so
we haven't interviewed
edward edward carlisle old eddie
he he he went to the pub
he was present at quiz night edward went
to the pub yeah
that was a different guy that one had a
mustache oh no no they went together
right
yeah i think so is that him yeah
you could call me clearly currently busy
you cannot talk and play piano at the
same time throw a brick at him
the late sunset filter does a lot for
this indoor that's beautiful
yeah what if you throw a coin together
[Music]
you just pull a knife out again did you
no
it worked
excellent yeah he's like a coin
[Laughter]
bounced
[Laughter]
you see i prefer not to spend the night
here at thornbridge it's haunted
gregory came along for a nightcap he
never admitted but i think he
understands that i find this whole thing
upsetting
what thing and wanted to provide the
death of family members
i believe we went to the stacks head
around half past eight well that's a
different time
can you tell me about zachary's behavior
last night i certainly didn't expect him
to commit suicide
sure he was upset by mother's supposed
we were surely it was her but he seemed
more engaged than usual you know
you should ask rebecca they had a long
talk
did you know that he had how good would
it have been i stole this from chat
but if uh hitman did the um daniel craig
southern accent the whole time
well he's detectives
these pods ah see
excuse me it's him no it's not him
he's a sweetie okay you're right so they
have both confirmed alibis now right
want to get the key
to that dude's office you might have to
knock him out to do that
hmm yes wait did he take your coins so
now you
you don't get that coin back you need to
take my coin i only have one coin left
lana you didn't see it but i used the
first coin i threw it into a bush and
then i
when i went to subdue the guy he turned
around and then i punched him in the
face
amazing he put hard it's amazing
incredible
okay so what's that out there what's
this a delta oh yes
have you gone like out into that like
garden or whatever yo this is a big map
yeah there's like a we go into the
greenhouse
oh topia berries
what's this happening yeah there's like
a whole mystery of that you have to find
the flash power
what the hell or the fuse you have to
find a fuse is that a mystery
what's this guy doing anything could be
a mystery if you want that's true
but then how will the plants get air
missing an iphone charger or something
yeah anytime i can't find anything i'm
like a mystery is a foot
i hope these pictures save he looks
totally like luigi
um do we have anything to i think i
think fans bee's office would be
a location of interest um because that's
the only
place that we've been told that somebody
was
outside of well i mean emma was outside
let's go to the pub
we need to confirm that they're there
two people saying they were doing
something doesn't make it a clear alibi
can you break in from outside do
anything in this office no we can get
him in
oh we need the freaking key yeah i'm
worried that you have to knock out
does anyone
this is a really interesting level like
i've never seen one that's
nobody's suspicious of you at all i feel
like we're not doing enough killing
i think you should go find the butler
end i think you probably could
kill alexa and still solve the mystery
yeah where's that where's that butler
he's he's been worked here for enough
years
let's go upstairs it is a little bit
annoying that
well i guess it's realistic that it's
not telling you where people are on the
map
oh that's him oh that's friends b that's
totally friends me
you conclude it by talking to him okay i
can conclude it and just say it was you
mystery solved
can we tell him we would like to go to
his quarters
ask him but make it sexy
i wanna see if he goes out of this room
oh yeah
what is he doing oh dusting about a
little rendezvous my bad
my bad between me and you i wish you
could pickpocket
are you literally just gonna go stand
watch this watch this oh mr friends me
loves corn
my chat said killing everyone means the
killer won't get away
that's true you murder all of them
oh damn it please stand back i'll check
it out
oh no here we go
good thinking john oh they both turned
around okay
just do your thing sir that's okay here
we go
damn it damn it your last coin acts like
he's so brave for finding a coin
you have enough evidence to present your
case for madame no i would like to go to
your office
come and see me okay that checks out i
don't know what we would have give me
your key
um you might be able to break the door
open it is made of glass
do you have like a maybe i think there
was a prompt for a crowbar if we could
find a crowbar maybe there's like a
maintenance area
watch this
what i can't hey you'll cut yourself you
gotta be careful
oh well climb through the hole yeah i
feel like you could fit
oh is there a window yeah that's what i
was wondering if there's maybe another
way in
it doesn't look like there is on the map
brilliant
oh
there's got to be a way to get his darn
key
poor thing alexa back from the dead a
make-believe funeral emergency
yes
catching the detective shooting windows
looking for evidence the crowbar is too
it's for the power thing
sabotage the fuse box right
wait yeah that's where again i feel like
the
oh the fuse but why
oh oh no watch this
genius do you think maybe he'll open the
door for some reason
no idea why he would but it'd be chill
that would be cool
someone's coming to investigate should i
do something or what i feel like the
detective outfit is just who you are now
then yeah turns it back on let's see if
he has the key let's see if he has
him yeah i guess he could have like a
monster key all right climb in there
and stuff an apricot down pie hole do it
oh [ __ ]
why did you need to do that oh my god
it's it's an assassin tactic okay no he
does not
he doesn't have the key all right wait
wait wait what if you put his outfit on
and
it could be in one of his pockets that
they did that in previously go up to the
door again
goes to the door again unlock
try try unlocking with the crowbar in
your hand it doesn't work
no wait it's not greyed out yeah wait a
second we were right crowbar will do it
i have the key
oh no no it it says missing okay okay
okay let's load the scene yeah i didn't
need to knock that dude
out the glass is all broken
the murderer must have shot the windows
out
good call the crowbar by the way good
call yeah
try to use it before
[Laughter]
get out of here you turn the lights back
on okay
oops go go go go go go go what the [ __ ]
did i just do
change cover oh you're taking a little
flipsies
all right
yeah [ __ ] you butler
all right you want to find out what he
was doing last night commit a murder
oh you could compare the handwriting
office
oh because that was the thing is we need
to get the notes yeah find out who wrote
zachary's note totally is that poison
poisoning
oh my god the poison used to kill
zachary
of course are mata
considering the frame the butler 47
zachary's diary yeah reedus diary this
is big
he was about to confess to the world
that he and alexa murdered her older
brother montgomery 46.
mr fernsby clearly didn't commit the
murder but he was unaccomplished i think
you have enough evidence
to convince madame carlo he did why were
you gonna frame the butler
why the handwriting doesn't match the
suicide letter in his room
proving he didn't write it himself
maybe you should tell him you are ready
yeah yeah
maybe you'll talk to him okay
it does want us to do more detecting can
you check your intel see if like
anything's been updated
because yeah someone conspired to do
this
oh there's people's rooms oh
do that do that do that okay in the
middle of the mountain towards the
center
stairs yeah we've really only been down
what's going on over there
they are you're right she's in there
should i go just
scoot her in the back there oh yeah yeah
clean kill just check the ribs
that was how we ended uh the last one we
got everyone into a secure room
uh and then we just murdered them it
counts
[Music]
could use some luck picks
this will open the door that's how i
open all my doors with newspapers
i feel like the housekeeping should have
like a master key or something
yeah yeah but we can't just investigate
their bedrooms are you [ __ ] it
you're a detective you're supposed to
have free range of this price
seems odd that is the door to rebecca's
room
there we go oh okay cool
uh another open laptop
she was also buying shoes wellingtons
definitely not suicidal from 9pm
to midnight last night that clears her
pretty well i don't know how fast this
poison works though what's up with this
dog
it's got a little peephole eyes what
what are you [ __ ] me
everyone's sweating wait there's nothing
in here
oh it's just so you can murder
it
well actually it might have just uh
cancelled her out
yeah okay whoa so it happened
maybe so it's either emma or the butler
i think well it was it was not the
butler is what they were saying is the
butler is an accomplice
to someone else's doings a separate
murder
yeah that's a hit man
dad what do you mean it doesn't exist
what is this it's just a different room
i'll double check
yeah yeah it's you can access it from
the other side
of the door detective you're just a
detective
don't worry about it oh [ __ ]
yeah just hit that book hit that button
pardon me get the apricot
why are they not upset with you i'm
leaving
i'm leaving there you go you're not even
there anymore hey
mister what are you thinking he's just
what he sticks his gun
what have you opened the door you never
closed it you dummy
oh right the kid oh he punched you in
the face
i pushed it i don't think it's so fast
oh the combat was evolved from when i
lost all there you go
there you go hitman combat congrats on
your engagement xbox game
yeah oh [ __ ] there's another guy out
there
you call them that guy i just registered
your joke
jacob hold on
my jokes take a lot of brain power to
actually comprehend
yeah yeah
this investigation is going swimmingly
this all confirms that arthur edwards
stole everything from adam carlisle
perhaps you should let her know how bad
it is 47.
what oh no something bad is going down
[Laughter]
oh my god i hope that you figure it out
[Laughter]
no it was a can of soda oh man
that would actually really hurt that's
good bye that
in hollywood uh you're
a lacia we're playing on pc
this stream though i should mention john
is playing on discord
and then i am capturing from his discord
so it might not look anywhere near
as good as it actually would look
um i think it's probably just 1080 but
it does definitely degrade
[Laughter]
nice i love it okay i think we might
have to reset here
yeah yeah yeah for sure you're onto
something though
yeah you can get into that room without
like getting in trouble
there were two of them in there though
no you could distract them yeah
is the two skulls people you've killed
i think it means i've murdered people
yeah
well they've murdered people just as
many people so you i'd say that
that's true okay we gotta we can
speedrun this yeah for sure this
yeah now we know what we need oh what
happened to my webcam
yeah it seems to do that whenever the
game reloads it gets like
no the um your webcam yeah it sometimes
just like drops it's really strange
um on obs it's it's very odd
all right crew bar here we go speed run
boom look at that
zachary's diary this is big
he was about to confess to the world
that he and alexa murdered their older
brother montgomery 46 years old
oh that's her mr fern [ __ ] don't slip on
the stick
i should have put the soap on the stairs
what could go wrong doesn't know
um you're finding trying to find emma's
right that
is alexa carlisle
all the dialogues catching up with all
your speed running yeah two possible
video game
and last one to be alive
mr ferns be clear that's right let's
close here
but i think you have enough evidence to
convince madame carla he did
that watch this
put a bag of sugar on it is the door to
rebecca's room
i can see from the log that rebecca was
in a conference call from 9pm
to midnight last night maybe you should
tell him you are ready to present your
findings
yeah looking cool detective
oh this is murder joker murder room oh
my god somebody's killed zachary
i hope the meeting's happening right now
i should just throw like a
like a bomb like a grenade right there i
don't know about that
you'll get the killer for sure yeah you
will whoever they are
this mission is all about justice yeah i
mean here's my question are you supposed
to tell
alexa and then kill her
because that's sort of [ __ ] up
yeah it's kind of awesome though
oh [ __ ] no i'm a detective
let's see why the detective has not been
doing full access in any case
which room is this okay this this room
is useless
oh greenhouse
oh they're coming jump out the window
and then
letter ooh is this emma's room
yeah it's emma's room okay so oh we can
get here from the balcony
all right oh somebody's looking at you
it's so good yeah
we got pretty busted there it happened
we did get fairly busted there
emma and gregory's room look away maid
there's nothing nothing weird about that
hey they didn't see it
sometimes you just go climb through a
window
don't worry about it yeah there you go
look at that little shuffle no hand this
would be terrifying
no lean he's just like grinding his
cheeks up against
the stone helmet
wow smooth ass butter nice we did it
first try and we can go check out the
greenhouse if we want
i'd love to like greenhouse key or
yourself to get it right it's just in
here
yeah look at that big brass tub
a keychain pendant for the greenhouse
yes what's that doing in emma and
gregory's room i wonder
and why is the key missing oh the key's
not on interesting 47.
a letter from emma's mother stating that
is the illegitimate child of alexa's
latest older brother
montgomery montgomery and listen to this
she claims to have witnessed alexa and
zachary murder him
the plot thickens you don't need to say
that this is
the thickest plot i've ever heard of
so it still could be emma i mean i think
it has to be
um but we need to get in the greenhouse
is what i gather
i don't know why i don't have the key i
don't know why i've got it that way
it was just like the the
change or whatever
what's that shoes yes
in my size no less
uh
oh you have is is
yeah but we don't have you know we can
do we can break it open
that's true the greenhouse made of glass
and as we know shooting the
glass on the doors it doesn't bother
anyone
yeah if fernsby's door is or any
indication you can get in this
greenhouse
crowbars do a lot of good here's the
back
yeah it's a it's a big house it's just
excessive yeah jesus
i don't even clean this i am working
very hard
i need you to back off i'll see you
later
when i murder you
it does look nice well maybe
okay
maybe there's something all in bushes
bit of a risk yeah it's fine who saw me
another damn maid
i love that the way that you're playing
this is just like oh we could just
follow her in doesn't that isn't that
what that means
oh well okay was that poison she just
dropped that shoes
nerd history has been solved
may have been that could be the poison i
don't know why you'd carry it on you
though she did drop some yeah
i think she might end up she's just and
then i'm not sure there's a dot there
oh the door's open oh yeah if you'd
excuse me
currently are you busy though what are
you busy with
you weird dude broken lab equipment oh
he was poisoned by something in here
that's what it is
it gets deeper and deeper oh my god it's
just like rescuers down under
i mean not that one first one so we need
a wrench
wait why do you need a wrench to fix the
uh
the potion machine curious
crowbar can't do it that sucks crowbar
could do everything
where do you think a wrench is um wrench
would be usually
in these games like next to someone
who's doing maintenance
like next to someone who's actively
fixing something they often have like
richard's lines right there it looks
like that could be here oh no it's a
pottery it's a pottery table or
something
that's just another crowbar oh wait
there might have been something on that
check the check the little it was a
crowbar again oh there's something else
though i think
there's the boat calm wait to ride you
later baby
yeah it totally is
a sweet boat okay
i have a uh plant in my hand or
something
well which is probably the plant that
was used to poison yeah
that's the culprit right the boy i want
to solve this murder yeah i do too
i mean here's the thing we know it's
emma we just don't know
can you talk to her how i was just i
don't know thinking
about zach where are you about how you
kill them
i told you um
be um thinking about the man that i
murdered
[Music]
okay so i can't keep questioning her no
what else so it wants you to repair this
thing is that what you're saying
yeah missing wrench repair distillation
wrench around yourself why do you need
to sure like why though
it's clearly the only thing you can
interact with poison that was used yeah
and then use the poison to murder alexa
yeah let's go what about this guy's
missing camera fuse
so long i mean we're making it long to
be fair
connected to like a fur there maybe
there'll be a wrench in the kitchen
could be it's yeah they're usually like
in a maintenance room or next to someone
who's fixing something not happening if
i ever saw one
life can be tough sometimes and that
detective are about
a wrench in the well uh michael john is
the one who's playing
um video probably is a little bit
glitchy just because
of the way that we're playing i'm not
playing it more coins someone else is
playing it
and i'm recording it so it probably
doesn't look perfect
unfortunately uh chat tells me there's a
wrench on the fountain
on the fountain apparently sometimes you
gotta wrench your fountains you know
all right i don't i know it i could've
sworn i
look what does that mean jacob i'm
scared they were like they were like
the thing was there were sheers and
different things
yeah but let's see
i swear we saw emma drop poison when she
fell
i swear she totally did yeah when did
she fall
i had like when you subdued corn wait go
back there's a unicorn you could touch
what right on the there
i really want you to do it but you
should watch there what that person is
watching me
oh i thought that was bubblegum it's a
cigarette
devastating
what who's complaining about old [ __ ]
probably emma she's a [ __ ]
all right well that's okay we'll break
it off on our way out we'll
we'll break it and then we'll go get on
the boat
yeah do it for you is that arranged for
right now that could be a reason it is
just sitting there wow thank you person
in chat we really appreciate that
thank you i mean i thought it would be
obvious that there was a good night's
space solder oh
all right what you doing here love
that's bro what are you doing
looking for this just throw
get out of here we gotta make
she's trying to make the poison a second
time
is that what we need to fix it for she
can't find her wrench
emma carlisle can't find her
wrench
yes yes yes wait didn't you did you just
put the rat poison in there
hmm oh my god we're gonna kill everyone
so i think what you need to do is is
leave and let her come back
right no that was what we just
confronted her here
but it was did it update the case file
because she was like why did you break
on me now so my thought was maybe she's
trying to make it again and you can
catch her doing it
but that means now that i've fixed it
yeah
showing lethal dosages brilliant they
didn't even try and [ __ ] hide it
so taking pictures does do the things 64
kg
yeah we know that because it's emma next
in line i'll do the job for you
emma i have uncovered enough evidence to
tell madame carla ah
okay we did it we did it i'll be like
she used this
poison and then i'll grab her and pour
it down her throat i don't know why
we're telling her it seems
really weird unless you think there are
more secrets
shut up stop tempting us i don't i'm
ready to present my conclusion
maybe maybe an opportunity will present
itself when we tell her
what if he tries to kill you because
he's in on it can we trust fans be
who knows the plot thickens you never
trust a fernsbee
no i keep calling him frisbee thicker
thank you frisbee take us to the matter
oh my god crowd the stairs why aren't
you yeah walk
slower you aren't there like a million
staircases oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my old bone
okay where the hell are we going the
whole time you're just like looking over
your shoulder at emma
yeah well you did fix her poison machine
for her
whoa he just walked through the security
guard
rude he owns the place just penetrate a
man without his consent
that's what the unicorn horns for what
do they have on that oh my gosh there's
the third floor
security guards have like they have like
glowing glowing
oh i think it's radios that makes sense
that makes sense did you just say
something
i think you did to frisbee what's up
yo frisbee what's up
classic great baby
we can look down
wait my gosh yeah jesus
the case file is 14 minutes activate
button
the case file is also like right next to
you it's in the room we should take it
oh it's somewhere yeah it says outside
your detective skills have gained you
access to the lion's den 47
what does that mean go claim your reward
i think two people just came out
your icons above the safe i wonder if
they might be some sort of a code wow
this is so much more
[Laughter]
oh don't mind me oh my gosh
hello this is so elaborate
um the case files on the balcony oh
she's going to this
oh it's already open
i just took a good look at it my old
braid how are you sir
so mr whitmer you've reached a
conclusion
yes it's me wisdom whitworth go ahead
emma right your niece emma carlisle
emmer carlisle i really have to go to
the bathroom
emma is not my niece she's my
daughter-in-law
and your niece no sammy this isn't
called i'm a child
i'm just montgomery and jacob are
telling me exactly what to do
that's preposterous you asked me to find
out what happened to zachary
would you rather not i'm the ultimate
detective
no go on i found a letter from emmer's
mother
jane he doesn't have a british accent
but he's still
saying emmer i don't know why he keeps
saying emma
like that he's playing the part yeah but
british people didn't say emmer
she believed
you have a mystery to solve well now you
are basking in the soul
of solving the mystery she said emma
jay she is a local girl
gern germs
[Music]
she's just bumping into stuff as she
faces back and forth
look at that hyena in the back yeah is
it like taking a [ __ ]
it might be a little curled up like that
found old floor plans from thornbridge
manor
that hitman picked up more than we did
that's for sure yeah did she get access
to his room from his
secret passage i didn't know that you
think
i found proof that she will try to we
did know that
well i'll have to take care of that yes
thank you mr whitmer you have not
disappointed
i promised you i would reward you
generously if you sold oh you wanted the
reward that's why you did it before
killing her
okay
i expected you might show up but to kill
me not help me
huh has she known so many things lately
so why not this one
i will give you the file on edwards
you've earned it
how's she know we want to kill her
though i don't suppose i could convince
you to deal with my daughter
do we maybe not have to kill her is it
going to change
yeah maybe what is j
i'll have to see to it some other way
then that's [ __ ] up you caught me
admitting to that
in front of a very real detective i
already opened that lady yeah you did
you press the button to open it you saw
it too you picked it up
who is edwards you guys i feel like i
missed that
she's a privacy good work 47
that's the file on arthur edwards
this feels really mean
and then you dive off of the balcony get
to the boat
oh push her off push her off
yeah well ugh
[Music]
how do i get
[Music]
i don't know that you want to walk past
her no no no no
it's fine it's fine it's okay where are
the stairs
look at him where are the stairs
let's just jump out a window is somebody
yelling
[ __ ] yeah someone's yelling help help me
oh okay
wake up he's staying
my discord got real pixelated come on
bud i'll look into it
that's okay we saw all the importance
that's true that's true
oh you gotta break the unicorn head oh
my god there's been an accident
what who could have done this [ __ ] oh my
god
you ran over oh gosh
nope wouldn't be you would it
wait we got the key it's not saying it's
an exit oh
oh [ __ ] john did you save right before
killing her
i did you should reload that save and
just like
wait why just just you'll just
you should do it what
the boat's gone that's right there
we don't do we don't have the key
anymore i'm confused what's happening
what
okay yeah just like jacob did you get
some kind of intel
out here or in here just just chill
right here this right here is fine
okay why hold on just wait
wait is she gonna commit suicide
no
oh is this your plan all along jacob
uh yeah yeah
did someone in chat lie to you i don't
know
did you lie chat it really seemed like
the perfect opportunity
oh a cool eagle maybe she's gotta go up
more stairs first
before she commits suicide why would she
though
okay i already asked but i feel like i'm
still not sure who is the guy that you
got the case file on
looking good
we've skipped all of the cut scenes uh
excellent
excellent
oh maybe she'll fall down the stairs i
don't know why this would happen why
would your
your target mysteriously die that would
be very unhitman
why would that happen
oh no an accident
oh my god oh my god
who put the soap on the staircase oh god
you know what i think i think i think
the first plan worked just fine
let's try this
i'm gonna soak the sudser up first
[Applause]
they heard the sound of the soap
breaking of the soap hitting her oh my
[Music]
god
to take care of madden carlisle hey
okay apparently she'll jump in different
circumstances
oh you could convince them if i told her
it was the butler probably
oh maybe or if you said it was zachary
like maybe if you didn't investigate and
you said it was zachary
because that would be her husband
committing suicide oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah because they were in on
something what's that noise yeah what
was that
john don't forget to grab that unicorn
horn on your way out i don't think we
can go that way now though because we
don't have the boat key
well we just gonna use the key go to the
other no we have the boat key
no it wasn't an exit it was like
oh it doesn't maybe if you go up to it
maybe because it's like a different
thing stupid staircase on this floor
being so hard to find come on
oh what the [ __ ]
there we go hey butler we just ran past
that
guy i accused you mystery solved bye
whoa whoa whoa
all right let's we got this
the unicorn horn will run to the boat
i don't think the boat's gonna work is
my concern
can you save first okay oh i broke it i
need to pick it up another
amazing it's like well he's too far
i couldn't possibly walk that far wait
no they're all american
i couldn't possibly walk that far he's
getting away
hey buddy oh hello mate it's british
yeah
boat key
but it's not an exit so
broken yep no
all right start walking all right back
there's only one exit
side of the map oh my gosh uh oh that's
he is a unicorn horn
that's true all this fuss for a pretend
funeral and why not
oh my god wow
why oh
she earned it he was here when the safe
in madame carlos was repaired last week
oh
there's a safe and madame carlisle's
yeah that's what you got the case files
from a bit late to get that intel
oh yeah you gotta hit somebody with a
bag of sugar
i really hope it like doesn't explode
get out of here john
no we gotta get out it's true there's
the coffin climb in
all right there that'd be empty wouldn't
it because it's for for a
fake suicide or whatever fake something
like that i have no idea not fake
anymore
no alexa is quite dead
let's put zachariano likes on the same
one
some cash that guy throw the sugar that
way oh sorry i was distracted
he seems like a safe bet yeah do it yeah
what
[Music]
[Music]
don't do that that's a bad oh gosh
they can't hit what they can't see i'll
distract them
cool bike
yeah there you go you think they'll be
like gregory or whatever and just go
oh yes oh god didn't even care
didn't even care about it oh wow
amazing audio's freaking out yeah the
audio is freaking out
nice all right i'm gonna go to the
bathroom and then come back real quick
okay
[Music]
90 seconds all right we'll time you all
right we're time with
them here i'm just going to stop the
stream and start the stream again
why is your stream broken or do you mean
john's the audio is all crazy yeah it's
weird for me too let me try that as well
oh it didn't fix it yeah
maybe it's on john's end or something
yeah it's almost up for me too
mad glitchy what is happening
i'm not sure it looks like an old
like splinter cell cutscene without like
pixels
i know now
it's my turn who is that what
it's miss burnwood oh of course yes
there's a lot going on here that i do
not understand you guys are only one
mission too right
three webcam moved again so strange
uh someone in chat said glad i was able
to play this game i spent over an hour
trying to link my i o account yeah
apparently they had like a lot of
connection issues um today yeah i mean
john's like offline right now
okay where's the hitman oh no oh gosh
he's the hitman
and he was the hitman all along
oh no
our friend you think you've won
the audio is so weird and
never this is his i feel like it's
getting better though it's not pixelated
anymore
yeah it looks it looks good it looks
real good
it'll fix itself surely huh trust me
that's better oh him nothing right i
think yeah
oh whoops i skipped it yeah it's fine it
was very confusing i don't know what was
happening
um synthetic
so i skipped the middle one so we can't
do this because we're offline apparently
bruce shaved his head
to become hitman tonight yeah yeah man i
want to see it
yeah i have a shaved head already so
that's true you did it way before bruce
what a copycat
yeah so you probably saw me anywhere
i wanna find his twitch see if i could
oh my god oh my god
is it shiny no it's just really bad
oh yeah i would have drunk goose on him
oh my gosh
here let me let me i'll put it over
somebody check and see it real quick
there you go
look at him look at bruce
oh wow oh
incredible i'm looking right it's just
now
his stream yeah oh she just
oh no it's eyeliner i think
i'm checking all right incredible
is this what is okay oh my god so
are these like mission interstitial
things oh this is really pretty
yeah this seems like an interesting
monkey
you got nicole olivia why is this so
spooky
i know fountain
you gotta harvest the dew that comes out
uh oh
when i was making fun of it the whole
time and then i heard myself say
something about alexa and i 100 did it
we put the r on it i was like alexa is
also dead
but it's you only do it when you have a
word that starts with a vowel
after the last vowel so like i used to
get may funnel for doing it at ign where
i'd be like hi my name is alana and
and it's because i'm saying and that i
say alana like separating
yeah it's only when there's another
vowel in there i don't know why we do it
but it's like
it's like a little transition yeah what
is this
though i don't know this feels like the
start of resident evil 2.
kill someone please yeah do you have any
intel oh a coin a coin
and then for the we're gonna get a soda
a fountain dew oh my god you're right
my god he's a genius i can't believe he
figured it out
okay there's somebody around here you
can i was a fan
oh that's good to know well now you got
a soda can to throw at somebody
at the unmocked van oh this isn't my car
oh my god it's lights we got to go down
here this is neat
this is a cool one alexa but why oh
we're finding olivia i thought we were
trying to call olivia
we're trying to find olivia
man we tried calling him his business
1847 is a little like nearsighted oh
wait now that fixed itself
i was like what are you talking about it
seems fine though it's fine now
maybe it's me
i tweeted about this and it seemed like
it was pretty consistent my vision has
gotten so bad this year we've been
compromised
like like degraded significantly
yeah just staring at stuff close to me
all the time
like two or three years ago
uh i guess it was two years ago my eyes
just went fast
yeah i mean i need to get glasses yeah i
i just can't read things that are far
away
really at all i'm gonna keep being like
maybe it'll get better maybe it'll go
back
i don't know but it will be my eyes i've
had reading glasses but
yeah it's a real bummer
you should get those little opera
binoculars oh you're right that would be
very fancy
it would be dandy oh yeah
thank you uh i appreciate that is this
game retrace i don't know do you know if
you guys know if this game has ray
tracing
i've seen some cool direct reflections
like that's what i don't know
especially in that first level it's like
oops the first level it definitely felt
like
dr pep pop get him yes
oh too far i always work by the book
it's impressed
it's fine i don't think he's oh he wow
he actually is your you definitely
should have knocked him out
but there's no one else here so well
listen i didn't throw that check this
out here we go
it'll also just knock him down it won't
kill him like the soap right
fastball oh my gosh
no he's dead phil step his neck now he's
dead
oh my gosh i always just like looking
for a needle in here i found joy
in the like they're not being an
animation when you snap somebody's neck
you just like do like a
you can't underestimate them i never do
we'll find them we're all in positions
isn't it like like why is it always that
you're uh
fighting your own team like
isn't that always the thing that the
agency be crazy that is really common
you know and like mission impossible and
stuff
because no i mean like every single hit
man
are you i like i never i couldn't tell
you the through line of any of these
games i could tell you what i did in
missions and i can even like kind of
tell you why some of the bad guys needed
to die but i could never tell you
anything that's happening to agent 47
well he doesn't even care from the other
side
i like his coach says that after another
sub gold
bruce is going to shave his beard too
damn
gotta make it gotta become an egg like
agent 47
goddess goals oh somebody's looking at
you
pretty much everyone in my chat is
agreeing that they do the same thing
is they don't watch the cutscenes who
knows
well i don't know what this man is about
all right
oh there's apparently there is a story
that connects these three games
according to raymond
i didn't know that yeah it was billed as
this hitman
3 is the last in the trilogy like
interesting well yeah i
was working on um uh bond
after this right oh yeah
you might just want to wait in that line
oh yeah i feel like i keep answering
you're reading chat and then telling me
what to do
i was just joking i am not playing the
line uh
i gave john my code so i could watch
john play look like it moves which is
what i'm doing right now so john is
playing jacob and i are just watching i
went to a line like that what was it at
the
there's some the bungalow or something
in
oh i remember not taking his outfit oh
we just gotta hang out with him
it's just you and me now well i couldn't
take his outfit so i just subdued him
for no reason
well i don't know why you would need an
outfit if you're just trying to get in a
club
right looking good today sir
hey i'm sorry you're gonna oh good
now don't show yourself around here you
gotta find you're targeting me
for sure hmm
there's gotta be a way around the back
let's just murder everyone there's all
those dudes around the back let's just
kill them
you spend all that time solving that
mystery you've earned it yeah um
that i have my chat says they're going
to enable ray tracing an
update interesting there will be rage
racing
trace those rays bro this game is real
pretty
pretty as hit man yeah
with all the charming jank what the [ __ ]
is
yeah these games are great they're
really fun
and they're all smart boys i got them
white dots
well we're trespassing but i feel like
if you get one who has a mosque
then yeah you know the issue of like you
know how people who
are of the same department and these
games can recognize each other i feel
like these guys
how would they be able to oh there's
people on the roof
too you might have to get up there
you're right wait so we just went
straight from a level into another level
like i thought this was like a mid level
but i guess this is a mid level
interesting
yeah you shoot that brick you you'll oh
okay
well what
well at least nobody noticed is he gonna
hold on let's
distract him can i just grab this guy
with coin i don't have coin i spent it
on a soda no
hey that was a well spent soda right
there oh [ __ ]
i
she looked hot that's a shame
all right let me get this this can't go
well surely can't go well
we can't miss okay there we go
club security let's go
i'm sure it's pronounced hole welcome to
club hole
later we looked at the camera and i
didn't like it
poison oh we could have poisoned that
guy
i mean oh you don't have any poison on
you here we go
what's up what's that oh it's a host it
is a weird
way to address your security but
you know you do you there we go good
stuff good stuff
why don't these people close oh why
don't these people close their laptops
it's so weird
i close my laptop like every time i go
to do anything
they're unplugged they're open and
they're unlocked
false sense of security it's ridiculous
i would literally get fired eliminate
ica
agents who knows how many there are oh
what's up
wow fun party is that me where
this is a girl with a longish white hat
look
i feel like i would dress like that
alana hey
hey what's up
all right agents where are you yeah this
is a weird one
the numbers are question marks yeah i
guess you just gotta find them
oh yeah that is it you just have to
track them down how are you supposed to
know when it's them
i don't know maybe it'll just like pop
up i have it for a really long time
i have to look at the backs of
everyone's heads my barcas
for a really long time i've wanted to do
a dj set that is just entirely
um music from the hitman games because
they have this really specific kind of
house that is like
it's all the exact same bpm in every
single game like that club music is
all the same
that's an agent right there big bald guy
how do i turn off
the camera yeah try scanning the camera
with your camera
right yeah that'll turn it off usually
that's like a security room well i mean
it opened a freaking locked door so
that is technically true
no but can i
[Music]
secretly quietly
do this
yes you can
[Music]
yeah this is an agent you think
he does look like elite forces okay we
gotta get one of these dudes
that's security no no no oh
that's our manager yeah
damn it time for a nice lean we gotta
kill one of the gang members and take
his clothes
what are the gang members look like they
said like they had like uh
uh like a motorcycle
club yeah oh there's our best friend
oh we love a car bar
gonna open so many doors
get the crowbar the door open don't
worry about it back to people's heads
yeah you gotta you got a box code you
got a barcode nope
nobody hey i'm a bartender now
if these games had a dude with that
specific accent it would be so much
harder to take his hit manning seriously
don't mind me i'm just standing next to
the wall i don't know why you gotta
worry about it
yeah it's not a big deal hammer
oh soda yes the old spring
you definitely just stole someone's
drink but oh look at this dude while him
out
oh this is amazing whoa steal his outfit
there'll be nothing left gotta get your
soda oh he's oiled up yeah that dude
manager right yeah yeah yeah worry about
him no it was yeah he's a dude on the
corner
you got his grill the lighting in this
game is really nice
yeah look at that led okay
we need to what was that
they're all bald down there they're all
agents that's why we don't know how many
there are because they're all
there's an agent right there next to you
is that a bar code she has like a like a
dent in her head yeah maybe you hit her
in the back of the head with a soda can
before
she's going hot though i respect it here
we go we gotta go back
what is the white circle that shows up
around you sometimes what is that did
you see that that girl just
the white what oh you can blend in in
crowds oh gotcha
i bet there's gonna be some like john
wick you're in the middle of the dance
floor
stab at people oh
like blade
exactly thank you very much
just like blade
[Music]
[Laughter]
but as long as you go away fast enough
not suspicious
where are we how many of these dudes are
there how are we supposed to find them i
don't understand what you want from me
look who's this cool guy dj
okay
cool he's looks like stink i want you to
get his outfit
we can poison the sausage
there's surely an agent in here yeah
death by killing us
uh is wait is this dude djing show me
what he's got can we walk close to him
please
i think this is this is tech this is
somewhere to hide bodies
uh like you got a fire extinguisher to
throw at somebody at full speed though
and like two soda cans dude wait for the
beat to drop
it's a white jumpsuit a cowboy hat he
doesn't appear to have any cdjs
no that's just a mixed oh you're right
yeah yeah yeah do it
do it oh no sorry i missed the entire
board so there is one cdj there
okay yeah i disregard sorry i did i
didn't see it
get into it gang look at all these npc's
too how much does loading is
that is a lot oh my god you could
trigger a climbing oh you see that guy
you see him
that was one showed up on the mountain
all right later nerds yeah you see this
you see the guy came up on the map
you saw him in the crowd see the red oh
nice could you hit him with a fire
extinguisher from here i feel like you
maybe want to go back to club security
but
all right okay i don't need it they're
people they're pretty busy partying in
there they'll never notice
one guy in a couch is he gonna oh he's
gonna recognize you that's interesting
hmm why are you friends with the dj how
i'm wearing a [ __ ] mask
how are you gonna know who i am
oh
you're right i should have changed back
to you absolutely because you might be
able to get loads of places
probably get back in there pretty easily
yeah that's true why are they all in the
bathroom
that's okay
good night trav4j i assume that means
you are leaving good night also
the twitch quality should be okay my um
sorry
i really need a moment could you wait
outside stream right seems good
they should look all right um
compression sometimes
more free than taking a [ __ ]
well no one's going in the dj booth yeah
i think you'll be fine which is weird
because at a certain point
the music should stop playing because
both of the djs are dead
so unless they have like a
a pre-mix that they're actually playing
like fake djs
then the song should be done any minute
now
also nobody in the crowd is concerned
about it both the dj's got knocked down
oh jeez oh geez over there now oh
about time it's fine it's fine they
don't know well so you just knocked them
both out right whoa what the [ __ ] who is
that
oh god
all right here we go
wait how did they know me oh turn around
oh there's two of them
understood what are these oranges why
does everyone know it's me
i'm security what the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
it's the dj i guess you hung around for
two weeks
anywhere hope you missed don't worry
it's fine
you just killed two innocent people and
oh god
i killed one innocent
okay so i'm loading before we kill the
dj
can we just see the dude i don't think
you've even yeah probably i don't
imagine you need to you know
that dude with the dot i think it was
because we triggered the lights show so
it loaded the lights
it lit up the rim i don't think that's
true i think it happened
i think i saw it before that happened um
oh really yeah well it's this guy it's
the guy with the dog
do you need to get the key out of the
box i think you just need to see them
look at them come on now
i mean at least he hasn't seen ui though
somehow no you're blending in it's fine
[Music]
no he's security i don't think he's one
of them
yeah all right
this is a really weird mission yeah for
real
there you go got the fire extinguisher
let's see is there a place to hide
bodies
somewhere else oh there's a little thing
right there to your left
oh okay okay here we go
anyone else around all right i think so
there's also a ladder that goes
yeah are you sure this is what you need
to do
i remember i'm convinced yeah john did
you see the ladder outside as well
i did not it's like right to the left of
the door
can i throw it at someone you can climb
it
all right g dump that one
come with me
it just seems like it would be the most
obvious
assault no this is this is uh
we're professional please
all right do your thing
yeah it seems like you're here we go
let's hype it up
get your dance on hands up
hands up in the chat it's a wednesday
night
we're doing it this is him man trigger
that climax
trigger the questions
nothing all right did i identify him
nope
uh no i i was pretty sure it was
unrelated
come out yup it's lit though yeah where
is he
it 100 is
[ __ ] this where
oh oh a clipboard oh you love those
blue intel view until
first you want to trigger the climax
slideshow as it's highly
dangerous you could kill someone with it
is what that's saying no it means that
you would have had to have like
uh rigged the lights first which i'm
sure you could still do ladders for
yeah you can still do it i just don't
know that anyone is just testing real
quick
in a convenient spot for that to even be
a thing i'm sure if you kill
everybody my chat did put their hands up
they're all these hands-off emojis
i'm super cute i know me too tiny arms
where is it nothing up here
can i pick up the stepping stool
you can drop it down here it's totally
going to be that's a cube
launch cube oh yeah fall right around
the person
why here it seems so weird that's
probably you can drop down to here
gospel hell yeah we're gonna do some
gundam models later i love that
hitman is uh a kleptomaniac as well
[Music]
yes him specifically he's the one with
all the impulses well how does he have
all the room for all of these things you
know
he's got a pouch like a kangaroo right
yeah
it's a very confusing mission this one
is confusing i'm not saying i don't have
a little light bulb guiding me around
well yeah that's because we haven't even
heard anyone's like suggestions
right
we did solve that mystery
if only we had listened to the cutscene
maybe it would have helped
no watch out not again
i'll get that closet
i meant to just close the door but yeah
they're fine nothing to see here
oh you know what we can grab well you
got the best game
who's got the best gear
i'll see you later perfect no you
replicated that perfectly exact
to a t
oh hey you need anything paddington
yes
where'd my dealer go paddington for that
little
is that this is
no no no come back no
louise people dance they're having a
good time no
no no no no
i'll loop back around maybe i need to
address this someone else
to see them it doesn't make any sense
it's just that they're all no no no to
uh
to not get noticed by the security
guards because i would go for one of
those mosque
dudes maybe
yeah what about the dude the toilet you
can just shut the door and then like i
tried to shut the door it should not
work that is true that did happen
know mesh shirt guy that's a good outfit
let me
open the door for you
nope there you go there you go
no one's even in here yeah these people
are just hanging out in the bathroom
recreationally
yeah i guess so but why come on
chamberlain checking in nothing to
report ooh what be
careful or you may not spot him until
it's too late what
what's happening well obviously you
random [ __ ] turn the tap on
and then came through the speaker yeah
i have no idea
what why are you suspicious
get inside get inside
i'd love to give you some privacy if i
could walk past you yeah behemoth of a
woman
she needs privacy to invest i want to
put on her outfit oh here we go
here we go excuse me
he won't let me in okay i think he's
designed to block
all right you're back in the pineapple
room oh poison
perfect all right your quarry is on we
can give hitman
36 diarrhea
is somebody searching for you is that
okay nope
all right i don't think anymore how are
you gonna get these punks like
isolated i can dress up as uh
the dj again so that i can
how do you live with them to to be in a
private area though like that's
so open ah security
yeah there already like drinks on his
loop
any reason he'd stop for a drink watch
out for this dude
didn't people recognize you as the dj
that was well anyway
well they will yeah but i can i can walk
freely around without
them
put them in the trash djs i want to go
buy drugs
first okay all right good there we go
again buy some drugs
find some icy agents
that was close yeah just keep on going
all right look at that hat
there it
i is to score i like to do
recreational drugs five drugs please
i just feel like if this dude asked to
buy drugs off of me i'd be like i'mma go
to prison
there is no way
you're under the stairs yeah that's
discreet yeah
wait okay yeah do i take his clothes
no i think you buy the drugs the drugs
[Music]
oh i can drug yeah i don't know how
though like this one's tough this is
brutal
[Music]
yeah you got two coins right all right
that works too okay sure thing that
dresses paddington
bag of medicine pills
all right there we go
all right paddington let's do this
okay i'll never recognize you now
yeah i don't know so where did he
so they must have a route that takes
them into discrete areas but it's still
only one more
yeah this that guy's looping yeah it
looks like he just goes in a big circle
around there
so maybe when he goes up up yeah like
this area
you might be able to get through
did you get the drugs she wants any
drugs i got drugs
oh you're holding them nope you're
holding rata pewee i'm holding a rat
poise
he's going to recognize you
we got a hollywood have to follow him
actor
he's like i think in the back room yeah
i guess so yeah
oh he's gonna stop look at the guy in
the red there
look at him go oh yeah he's jamming out
[Laughter]
following me go to a toilet not a bad
idea could you
close it no look i closed the door you
can't get through the door idiot you
can't figure it out you're right
it's the one thing about those ico they
can't open doors
approach
that's interesting cool dude's gonna
follow you now though i don't know that
that was the best call
you asked him to follow you did he
follow you okay
just do this one at a time until the
dance floor is empty and then you can
get away with anything
oh [ __ ] you don't like it you just got
it you got to take him out real quick
there we go okay
no no no
are you your outfit stashed now yeah a
little outfit corner
yeah that's great dressing room
all right why are these people running
around oh no
holy [ __ ] oh holy [ __ ] go go go walk
quickly
okay oh god inside bare legs it's fine
watch out for this dude i think
eventually he will walk up the back
yeah not having targets listed is
is is strange
and you're right about those dj's that
uh that song's still playing
they had a pre-mix that's disgusting you
can't be doing them things
[Music]
sometimes if i need to go to the
bathroom while djing i'll play a really
long song
that's my scene yeah [ __ ]
three people in there okay here we go
it's gonna loop around
yeah i think you're right or is he
i mean he does at some point
there's this little pit stop yeah yeah
do you have any security outfits
laying around anyway there's another
what's the outfit right there i think
it's yeah
it's nice perfect
everyone would have seen that come on
dude what the [ __ ]
ah coming back out okay maybe he'll come
up now though
son of a [ __ ]
oh oh oh it's going a different way okay
that way over there is pretty empty
the fan we can sabotage the fan
um josh we don't do guests on that show
um i don't work in that industry in any
capacity somehow i don't know
yeah we don't do guests on players
listening because it would change the
tone of the show so much
i don't think why not
oh we're dressed as security again now
okay well he's just looping
back around so we'll leave him for now
we'll even be for now
okay let's go see if we can trigger
some other see because look there are
these biker dudes
oh yes i just don't know how you're
supposed to get that guy isolated
that's the part that i'm confused about
that's like special get out of my face
uh how are you supposed to get those
disguises
we need to offer them drugs there you go
you're padding to the back
oh yeah but the problem is that the ica
agents seem to recognize you so even if
you were to offer them drugs
then yeah i think they're just gonna be
in trouble no matter what
this is maybe really hard maybe we
have them chase us into an abandoned
building or something well that's why i
was thinking maybe you try to get the
outfit
of one of the people that's wearing a
mosque oh no i recognize the dj
i have an idea i have an idea i like
this idea whatever it is i don't know
what it is but i know i'm gonna i love
it
listen you know what i'm all about i'll
give him a muffin
yeah good idea good call good call that
was smart
that was smart oh security sami
hold on yeah but now you've got a
shashka
now i'm a biker there you go
you can't kill a biker here wait maybe
because i was standing in the hallway
let's see
there we go okay throw a soda from here
nobody will know
why are you trying to dress like a biker
though because yeah
you can get back there it's like a even
more area
the club has a bike is only section okay
that checks out all right
you're just bartending you're just
bartending you shot it like through his
gun
yeah over penetrate well how are you
going to hide these guys
right now oh yeah the thing right there
look at us go this is a great club i
would like to go here
this place is good too so many options i
would stand in the corner
and not interact with anyone there's a
laptop over there too of course there is
you know it
hope that security guard's coming back
oh [ __ ] i see his dot you got it you got
it you got it
you put it in a fragile box oh no the
other one
no the guy we need to take out is
downstairs right now there's that left
hand lanes against that hits on that
tech guy and that's got those secrets on
it
oh
screen projection
[Music]
oh it was a little it was just like a
distraction cool
okay oh i can't pick up my broken can
oh no well better load again
so yeah so what's the purpose of any of
this
it's just new area new area to explore
okay somewhere to go go up
see what's up there's also downstairs
there's a pikia area downstairs
all right so we've got more options
wait do you do you have a key for that
cool
there's a whole thing back here ragnarok
disciples huh
what the [ __ ] is going on what is this
it's so huge
oh my god we're getting
somewhere then
yet wait what pizza delivery
oh my moped why is this so elaborate
this is so this is a very strange
mission
this is harder than solving a mystery
way hotter
like why do you need to do anything are
you trying to get in here
[Music]
what is this maybe you have to take out
one of these dudes at a time
and then you wait for that oh like we it
won't unlock the next guy until
we did have two at once though didn't we
oh i don't think so i think we've only
had the one
i believe though oh [ __ ] a distraction
wait
did they just notice the projector
yeah i think you're right i think that
is the projector they're noticing
oh dude looks so far away yeah we've
been here before damn it
these maps are so big yeah for real
there's so much that's going on
inside the building
all right well back in we go all right
there's the downstairs biker area i
guess we can check okay go check that
out
oh that guy knows me i don't know oh no
okay
that's a maybe that's an agent
he's got a ski mask on tim's here i knew
it
target probably he's looking at you
oh no that's you looking so strange i
don't understand the logic
like so it's oh oh oh oh
here we go it's picking them at random
is what's happening here to get one
it is picking random npcs to be the ica
agents
i don't have my fiber wire but i don't
know what you're getting a puppy knife
though
that's true yeah we do all right silent
build some
guys to death yeah you'll be fine
yeah all right cool
progress
that so that's our ticket to knowing
report are you there
no no oh thames oh no
that's our ticket to knowing
down are you all sleeping out there we
could not have stacked the deck more in
our favor
and still what the heck is that a new
earpiece it's a mine
whoa so like when we're a security guard
and other random [ __ ] recognize
us
they're an agent um
yeah because that dude was crew oh
there's another biker on camera whatever
it's fine
that dude was crew and we're biker and
he recognized us
yeah that would be odd
i think it is selecting them at random
which makes this like very
i just don't know what the rules are i
wonder how many they're even gonna be
right there could be like 25 i know
here
there's someone laying down in there
what the [ __ ] that person
did you do that sure no i don't think so
that's somebody else oh buddy you okay
you haven't having a good night you're
all right well he's like he's laying on
his side so
it was so awesome every so often you
just have like a world ending [ __ ]
it it it i've never seen a nightclub
with that many empty bathroom stalls it
does not exist yeah
yeah yeah hi oh yeah hi
uh what's this what is he he's
downstairs
let's test it out yeah here we go
oh my god
oh gosh
oh there's someone below me someone in
my chat just said
i think it's the guy uh there are five
and all will be able to recognize you
oh my god i mean that is helpful hello
are you gonna head down to that like
biker yeah i'm trying to
find my way this place is massive
yeah the one that just like wanders
around that one's just tricky
yeah he's just always surrounded by
people
we might have to lure him that guy's
still going
i was thinking possibly
if we get him to chase us then we go
back to the drug dealer area
let's do that right now let's try it
right now yeah yeah that has worked
before
although i think other security starts
chasing us
at that time let's see let's find out we
got away with it though didn't we
before they know it
so somebody read a dusty so
okay there he is
okay protect me cool
the bin might be full though you know
okay sometimes you can't yeah sometimes
you can only have a certain amount
he's not coming we'll find another bin
i'm right here
hello hello
[Music]
look at this fine ass
nice dude yeah that works super well
full
[ __ ] is it full oh somebody's coming oh
get out of here you haven't seen [ __ ]
walk away just walk away honey
what you're gonna have to kill her too
are you walking towards us john somebody
else is coming
somebody else is coming i just feel like
you should leave somebody else
coming oh my god oh oh another hapless
bystander
oh no that's fine it's fine it is fine
nobody yes
it's probably fine
[Music]
i can't go through this door oh [ __ ] oh
it's not real
no one saw that it was a biker
nobody's surprised we're all good hello
friends who are just joining thanks for
asking about my dad just my hands
that's still sort of bad appreciate it
uh
look it's like we're watching john
playing right now so he can play and we
can watch
let's just go back they're really fun
games okay
it's down from here
oh yeah yeah yeah it's right here see
it's your bros
see that guy yeah maybe oh yeah you're
right
okay so they are back here unless it's a
biker unless those are packers
there's another one that's not a biker
that's not a biker this is not secure
that's him
how long does it take for them to like
acknowledge then like why is it not
another one that just hangs out no
[ __ ] he's not [ __ ] the door closed
run backstage get backstage
yeah turn the pack case on that'll tell
him damn it yeah turn on that rack
yeah oh [ __ ] another dj where do you
come from
oh god the vegan hitman is hard
bringing him in it's hard
uh oh look at that
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so that's that dude that's just the boss
do you have to let them talk about stuff
guys never like maybe he always is
because that first one outside wait
these are i don't like that new security
guy
the one from munich he's not right he's
not right
it's the one from munich hey right in
the end i'm just trying to avoid him
until we got gray sorted out
don't worry the boys are trying to stall
him as much as possible
uh maybe i should just call them get
over and done with
okay i need to think where are the other
agents though oh you got into
intel oh thank god
you got a security private meeting why
though
oh go over to the agents will i give you
more information
oh good thinking intel who to thunk
okay you got your dress those are just
ones you already got yeah
[ __ ] so how do you
arrange a private meeting i don't know
and i don't know why you need to do that
you know why
boom you're in business now in a
baseball bat too
i don't think we have anything no
six nine six nine maybe yeah good stuff
give that a try
devastating and surprising
okay oh
nothing oh my i guess we could dump a
body down there yeah maybe
i guess yeah what
oh it's that painting it's the jesus
nice that's a nice little easter egg
yeah
oh stephen are you saying you haven't
coveted
i'm so sorry to hear that i hope you're
okay you need to be the club owner
yeah well come over the positive i hope
you're okay bud that's the worst person
no that is absolutely awful or maybe
what are they alright over there
where i saw like a person through one of
the white dots through the wall they
were
dragging something
yeah that was that way yeah i'm dragging
something
who's searching for what oh [ __ ] what is
this
what is this i'm a man how dare you
what are you [ __ ] oh no that didn't go
well i think you should leave there we
go
but why oh boy that's okay
this one's just real rough man he's
gotta punch somebody
yeah it's true
before we uh got that third guy
damn it oh [ __ ] all right hold on the
question
is yeah you can do the same thing yeah
good save good choice of save
what are you going to throw at his head
you lose me bud i'm right here come on
get back here
oh quick draw
all right nobody saw this one
whatever yeah it's fine go cry about it
karen
this shouldn't be happening
no it should not karen okay there's only
two more
i still am not really clear on how to
find them yeah
that's one you think yeah it's just like
what triggers like identifying them
so i really don't know oh we don't have
the keycode anymore either oh i know
where to get it
it's your bros hey buds
just a bunch of bros hanging out don't
worry about it yeah
okay there's your key card
not a thing something doesn't feel right
about this
oh gray is one of them
that's why it wants you to call him he's
been listening oh we have to we can call
someone
oh you know how it gave you that prompt
before i could be wrong that's how i
understood that interaction just now we
had a phone
no it's gone it was on the message
machine thing but it said that you
didn't have the number
oh
but we don't know how to call it missing
maybe they'll say something go by
yes just call him
i need to think so where's we'll need to
think
what about their legs
[Laughter]
i can't not do it that voice is so funny
it is really good
i love those orcs
all right there's a fella oh gray is
dead apparently okay thank you gray is
already dead that's why gray didn't show
up
wow because he's dead threw a soda can
at his face
okay so it is sort of tied to their
dialogue don't worry
yeah that's one that's been right there
but i'm better i'm not convinced i feel
like you've said loads of them all of
them when the men know that one you got
to push off yeah push that one off that
balcony it's like alexa all over again
exactly
oh wait hold on soda oh no you
they're probably going to notice if you
do that sadly i'll
probably pick up on it it will give you
a bunch more points but yeah i mean
you're also in any
kind of problem oh that's that guy all
right there's stairs here
okay and you've got one dude to kill and
you'll have one left
let's check the guy in the rafters
who are those guys wow who put down that
couldn't be me oh they're the bikers
they're the bikers
i killed them so long ago
all right who are you i don't i'm not
convinced
touch your ear i dare you
see he's looking he's looking around
oh you're right you're right you're all
right all right
okay crack the code
and we just gotta kill him
so wait are these your agents they're
i don't know actually it doesn't matter
okay the question is well one one of the
questions is
this remote audio linux this is the
final game can i throw it or do i put it
hello
mauricio
can you push the dude on the ledge over
the edge
yeah you can get both of those security
guys to move
they ain't both moving oh my god they're
both at the same place oh [ __ ]
oh do you have an explosive device push
them both
push
[Music]
how do they see me
where's that like other dude too showed
up
can't i'm getting away
i was looking down on my keyboard
amazing okay we got this yeah totally
this i wish i could grab
both of them by the pants and flip them
over yeah give a little flip
you think i could you think i could uh
shoot him both through the head at the
same time
over penetrate go right without them two
kills
i bet you i bet you no they're not lined
up i don't think so
i don't think they'll be lined up there
you go there you go
one bullet whoops damn it
uh i did not get rid of the cyberpunk
chat chat i'm just not at home
which is why you know the lights
different headset's different i wanna i
wanna i wanna try
shooting them both in the face i don't
seem to feel like it's going to work
but i respect your intentions
it keeps the halos load in there let me
stay here i think there's a gap there
that just isn't obvious
i believe i don't
oh
[Music]
they looked right at you what was that
that you just threw in
the remote mine okay
can you explode it though could you
detonate it right now
then it killed them
oh my god oh
why couldn't you blow them both up no
it's a it's an audio mine it's just yeah
it just goes
hey look over here oh god you're making
poison
oh wait what is this that's an explosive
device explosive
i think we found our answer
[Music]
oh holy
[Laughter]
just keep going keep going just run just
run i don't know
why isn't he gonna make this 47 never go
more than where did the exit go
where's the exit oh oh you got to go up
you're underground
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] so why does it say
you're in combat there's nobody
even able to get that gun out just in
case
well holster it you could go get your
your paddington outfit back so they
don't recognize that
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] all right
there it is said the exodus
right somehow to my right this way yeah
no
that's left is it
look left go left look left there
see there it is up there somewhere okay
you gotta go up more stairs
i mean if you look at the map you'll be
able to figure out probably the speedo
guy's coming
here we go oh thank god come on come on
oh sorry
it's nothing it doesn't bother them when
it's on your back
the minute you're holding it okay speed
okay he's like i gotta get out of here
he's very suspicious
oh no he just punched him
amazing well okay okay you got him i
think
how do you get out oh god okay this way
this way
not no john not necessary
it was necessary he had an exclamation
point are we still underground
i think you're on the right level you
see the toilet really no it's just a
[ __ ] toilet
no no no what the [ __ ] you're on the
right there's not a storm
oh god oh
the doors are very tidy
oh my god
you gotta get out john i believe
oh [ __ ] reload
all right man
that bomb was um that's a good play
right there
you could throw it at him and then run
away and then detonate it
that's true but i think they'll notice
it is the problem oh 100 percent
i meant to throw it at their feet yeah
yeah but then it locked on
oh one's walking away oh my god yes
oh he fell they but they didn't they
didn't see you
yeah they're just searching did i get
both of them i think so
yeah i need a report you've done it oh
my gosh you've done it
nice and nobody's the wiser
she's pulling the plug and everybody's
already dead
oh this way okay this is oh we can get
out bikers oh yeah i think you're right
bikers exit through the back of that
outfit the outfit paid off in the end
my outfit did pay off yeah your outfit
i just got to get out all right do you
think it's going to be good i have a
bike again
i want to keep going i don't know about
you guys no i'm gonna i gotta i got a
roll
it's 10 30. as much as this is super fun
i'd be down to do it again at some other
point
[Music]
yeah i'm pretty tired as tempting as it
is
i drank a bunch of caffeine at like
seven so
yeah yeah that'll get you yeah
oh oh who's that well he's running in
the different directions so it seems
fine
oh i thought i could halt over that yeah
i would have thought so too you can't
even walk over it apparently
you can only vault over certain things
that are the same the bike pants are
really tight you know
yeah you know his balls are too big
we did it yeah oh my god
that one was that what took longer than
the mystery that one was
also a lot less fun it also was way
it was not very clear yeah once we
figured out like the game mechanic that
if we find the person with the dot and
then watch them
put their finger on their ears yeah
that's the way it goes that is the way
it goes
um well that was fun you guys well hey
thank you all so much
this is really fun and alana thanks for
the code of course this is the thing
this is a fun way to
stream just like watching the party
these i mean there's such good games to
watch because you all have an input
because you're solving solving mysteries
i don't think i would have been able to
do it without you i think i was thinking
shot people and run yeah i was thinking
i wasn't going to say anything so i'm
glad you did but that was my exact
thought so
good stuff okay
well cool all right well i guess i'll
catch you all in the flippity flop
yeah wow all righty see ya
cool um
i guess bye everyone i just i just
posted a server ip i don't know what
that was for